we are so excited to have one of the
most iconic pop stars of all time at
this desk she just released her first
original album in 20 years called the
body remembers please welcome the one
the only and our friend of the show
debbie
[Applause]
i love you so much i love you more than
words can say and debbie really
i just thank you because you came on the
show really early oh my god zoom you
were at your house you were taking out
the trash doing your invite and these
yes exactly
doing your whole life as a musical
now can i ask um why you name this the
body remembers what a great title thank
you you know it felt so i heard a great
word recently nostalgic
and it feels like everybody craves
nostalgia like we all want to live in a
modern world we all want to be who we
are now but we want all the good feels
from those times that we remember that
our body remembers that those first
concerts oh yeah that first kiss we we
also remember the traumatic stuff and
you know i'm someone who loves to
disguise layered messages in hooky dance
songs so it's like you can be enjoying
it hey and then you're like wait a
minute i think i just got something
richer from the lyric and so that's what
this album is and you know joey mcintyre
is on the album also we remade lost in
your eyes as a duet i love that and
[Applause]
i hear you have some breaking news
so there's a couple of things first of
all i'm going on tour this summer
i'm on the east coast okay i'm in jersey
i'm on long island oh we're coming i'll
send you guys a car okay um
but then there was something else you
know i'm working on a holiday album this
year too
debbie does christmas
changing the title to that that could be
a really fun title that is hysterical
but what i wanted to share with you also
because i was talking about joey is he
and i are duetting again we co-wrote an
original joey mcintyre diet for the
holiday album as well
and my dad who's also a joe my two
favorite joes
he and i sing like christmas together oh
my god
you and christmas i can't handle i can't
wait so bring it on
um we like to deliver news pop culture
information here so will you hit some
headlines with us yes
right all right debbie kick us off okay
first
first we've got some exciting news about
in-flight dining oh i love a good
in-flight meal on today's food news
so
veg news reports delta is doing
plant-based meals for the first time
and here's what's on the menu an
impossible burger topped with
manchego on a brioche bun
pan fried cauliflower cakes with creamy
pesto orzo that sounds amazing and
meatless lamb meatballs with spinach
rice and feta delta says the choice is
not just because plant-based meals are
delicious but also because they're more
sustainable many of these meatless
options use less land and water than
meat
i love this i do i do
um as a frequent flyer
um i i don't really want meat up in the
sky i don't know why i don't want the
fish i don't want the meat
um i always forget to order the
vegetarian meal
i travel all the time i would love
like i i'm so into this may delta be the
first of many airlines to do this why
not
yeah right
all right
next up we've got we this is fun we have
an 80s makeup style that ticktock says
will be everywhere in 2022. the list
reports something called blush draping
is all the rage
i don't know what it was but it's
applying rosy blush with a real heavy
hand and extending it all the way up to
your temples okay now you are two great
beauties uh are you is this something
you do
i mean i don't but i'll try it you'll
try it we have some flowers okay i know
i have some you sent me some flower
beauty spoons
i love sending you flower beauty debbie
oh how's that coming in with you look
that went on thicker than i thought it
was going
oh sorry let's see
oh i love it do you i love it and screw
it i'll do this side too okay
a little heavy-handed that's okay
it's really like groovy it's kind of you
know they say 80s but it feels more 70s
right you know what's amazing is like i
feel like all of a sudden i i
i have more umph i have more color i
have more like you know
something no rossi i mean like a hobby
doll or something i feel like i'm on the
cover of your christmas album you know
what i mean like it's cold out here by
the way you are looking very crisp
oh my god but i you know what that just
i that's the crazy thing like color
changes everything i feel like i went
from a little sullen
to like really poppy yeah yeah yeah i
love that it looks like that because you
got like a groovy vibe anyway you can
kind of rock anything but that listen if
you put on look put that foot up again
debbie put that foot up
you throw on that and a red lip yeah
you're sad and your entire
energy is gonna change
just a little bit of footwear and a
bright lip i swear to you may i you will
you just get in here get in here see
this is a real friend right they need a
little bit now you've got like that
lovely just winter little chill button
okay yeah yeah better hi hi okay now i'm
beautiful all right this story i had to
sneak in because i just loved it so much
um breaking news you guys
brady is back why no one
it didn't last people report that after
being retired for one month brady has
announced he's coming back as
quarterback for the tampa bay buccaneers
this will be his 23rd season five-time
super bowl mvp says he's just got
unfinished business on that field and my
favorite quote comes from stephen
colbert's response on twitter he says
tom brady got one taste of what it's
like to help kids with math homework and
decided to return to being tackled by
the largest men in the world
oh every mother can relate welcome back
[Music]
you